december 7th forever the day that lives
in infamy and that's because 80 years
ago today more than 2 000 americans were
killed during japan's attack on pearl
harbor in hawaii it led to the u.s
declaring war on japan entering world
war ii and eventually leading the allies
to victory
tom chakansky is senior curator at the
national world war ii museum in new
orleans and he joins us now to talk
about the importance of pearl harbor
remembrance day
tom welcome to quick take thank you so
much for taking the time to speak with
us on what's been a very busy day for
you
um for a lot of people
9 11 has actually eclipsed december 7th
as the day of infamy especially those
who are young
how do you explain pearl harbor day to
those who only remember a post a 911
world
well pearl harbor really is
very much equivalent
to 9 11.
and of course the the biggest thing is
that although
911's triggered a long long war
the pearl harbor attack
brought the united states into a world
war
and one that we won as opposed to what's
happened after 9 11 where we're still
kind of sifting through
the fallout from everything
tell us what your museum the national
world war ii museum in new orleans is
doing to remember the day i understand
you have an exhibit on pearl harbor and
it's going to be around for a while
yes we've just recently opened infamy
pearl harbor remembered and that's a new
special exhibit that looks at how pearl
harbor is remembered and that'll be open
through june but of course in our
permanent galleries we have another more
extensive exhibit that examines the road
to war in pearl harbor and the actions
of that day and we also include pearl
harbor in our signature film beyond all
boundaries which gives a 45-minute
overview of the war so
a very important uh event for america in
world war ii
and of course we're still in the middle
of a pandemic so i wonder how
the current situation covet protocol
plays a role in your planning for
the exhibit and and how you're
commemorating the anniversary
well we are fortunate enough that given
the current situation we've been able to
have live events today but given our
experience over the last two years we
also continue to have virtual
virtual uh presentations
because it does reach so many more
people
yeah you i mean it makes it accessible
to everyone in the nation and the world
really i was thinking back to how when i
was growing up i remember seeing world
war ii veterans uh going to pearl harbor
to commemorate december 7th speaking and
each year the ranks would get thinner
and thinner which of course makes sense
that doesn't really happen anymore
because most of them are no longer with
us and this week alone for instance we
lost uh the last surviving member of the
band of brothers edward shames and
former senator bob dole another world
war ii hero
do we know how many surviving world war
ii veterans there are left
i believe it's under 600 000
and that's of 16 million that served in
world war ii
and you were able to recruit uh one of
those veterans for your exhibit as well
because they'll be speaking he'll be
speaking to
uh your audience and and
and kind of commemorating the day for
your audience
yes at 11 o'clock we had a presentation
that included the last
uh
server the last survivor of pearl harbor
from louisiana
as far as we know
that's pretty impressive and i'm sure a
lot of people were looking forward to
his remarks and what he had to say
without
so many living survivors of world war ii
who are able to
share their stories firsthand we really
rely more than ever
on manufactured depictions of the war
hollywood depictions really we're
talking about tv shows and movies as
well so if you could talk a little bit
about how the band of brothers tv shows
like that and movies shape our
understanding of what happened
well at first i'd like to say that we're
very fortunate because over the last 20
years that the museum has been here
we've been collecting the personal
stories of those veterans and so they
may be gone today but we have recorded
their comments and their remembrances
and we're able to include those we have
15 individuals i don't think any of them
are along with us anymore whose stories
and remembrance of the day at pearl
harbor are included in our exhibit on
video but of course for many people
the movies about world war ii do play
a great uh
point in their understanding of the war
and it also helps that
from time to time these movies come
forth and they reinvigorate people's
interest in the war uh and it's not
unusual when you consider that many
films were made in the 70s and those
similar topics have been remade today
and it again
gets people interested and they
want to find out what their ancestors
did in world war ii and what happened in
more detail
what book or movie would you recommend
to young people who are
i mean obviously know quite a bit about
world war ii but want to really dig in
and learn more about what happened what
what's what's a personal recommendation
that you would put forth
well i think
dr ambrose band of brothers is a very
good book because it covers one group of
individuals
from the time they get into the service
until the end of world war ii and of
course they're just one group but
they're a great many uh groups and
that's a good place to start and then
after that i would recommend you find
something about an ancestor perhaps that
you had uh almost every unit's got a
unit history
find that and learn about what your
people did that's a great great piece of
advice i mean finding that personal
connection will always bring people
closer to the event at hand what
surprises you the most as visitors go
through the national world war ii museum
on pearl harbor remembrance day as as
they comment on the exhibit and on uh
the state of the world and then how the
country has responded to these moments
of challenges in the past
oh uh you know one of the things that
that most surprised me i had a dinner
with a curator last week and and we
often have people who talk about uh that
they were
at pearl harbor and we didn't have
anybody there who was at pearl harbor we
had a very original fellow he said you
know i'm the youngest survivor of pearl
harbor my mother was four months
pregnant with me when pearl harbor was
bombed she was there and i thought well
that that we've gotten younger and
younger with our veterans and survivors
and that one has probably uh topped the
list
it's good to know you'll you'll be able
to draw upon his expertise later on
if nothing else i want to bring it
forward to today because defense
secretary lloyd austin today released a
statement honoring the 80th anniversary
of pearl harbor day and he linked it
with the us's current efforts to protect
the indo-pacific region how would you
explain that link to your museum's
visitors who come through and are trying
to understand
how the past connects with what we're
seeing today
well after world war ii we made a
commitment to
the people in the pacific that we would
defend
their rights and
their countries and we made a
constitution
with japan that said they would only
have a self-defense force and so
we have a long-standing obligation to
protect these peoples uh we can no
longer afford as america wanted to do
before work before pearl harbor to say
it's a foreign war it's
uh happening elsewhere in the world
there no longer is an elsewhere in the
world we're all one world together and
we must act that way
well said tom jakansky really appreciate
your joining us today on this 80th
anniversary of the attack on pearl
harbor tom is senior curator at the
national world war ii museum in new
orleans thank you so much